pare-chocs inexistant toutefois ces
prêts avant arraché pare-brise brisé
font partie des nombreux dégâts
apparents sous ce véhicule réduit à
l'état d'épave
hier soir aux environs de 22h30 après
avoir percuté 7e rambarde au niveau du
pont des chaînes à fort-de-france ce
véhicule a terminé sa course dans ce
canal se déversa principe eaux de pluie
et eaux usées l'on pourrait penser à un
banal accident dû à une vitesse
excessive
mais les causes réelles sont
surprenantes comme vous le constatez sur
ses photos et ses vidéos amateurs cet
accident a mobilisé des moyens très
importants hier soir dont des plongeurs
justice mais aussi des unités de la
police nationale un périmètre de
sécurité s'imposait car l'attraction de
la soirée a attiré bon nombre de badauds
et de véhicules dans le secteur
en l'absence de chauffeur et deux
passagers dans l'habitacle craignant le
pire
les courageux plongeurs ont ce côté sans
succès c'est aux bouses et nauséabonde
aux environs d'une heure du matin
c'est le moment que ce parvient à sortir
les pages de ce grand canal
ce matin grâce aux indications d'une
carte grise retrouvé dans le véhicule
les enquêteurs remontent à traces d'un
jeune homme de 23 ans il était au volant
du véhicule au moment des faits il
déclaré aux enquêteurs qu'il voulait
tout simplement se suicider est pressée
d'avoir volontairement percuté ce pont
est raté son coup il parvient à
s'extirper du véhicule
il remonte par cet escalier au niveau de
la chaussée présentant de sérieuses
séquelles de son accident ce matin il a
été admis aux urgences du centre
hospitalier pierre dac hyp man à la
mi-mars